[Música]
aquí comienza ella soy el programa
feminista de france24 la historia de hoy
nos lleva a Francia porque la iglesia
católica de ese país se vio obligada a
hacer nuevos reportes de abusos sexuales
entre sus filas entre otros casos esta
vez el cardenal la de Jean Pierre ricard
admitió haber abusado de una niña de 14
años 35 años atrás una revelación que
contribuye al aumento de la
impopularidad de la iglesia que ya suma
más de 200.000 víctimas de abuso
sexuales en el país desde los años 50
veamos el reporte para entrar en
contexto y enseguida regresamos para el
análisis
los obispos se reúnen en Lourdes al
suroeste de Francia para hacer frente a
un nuevo escándalo de acoso sexual en el
centro de la última revelación el
cardenal Jean Pierre ricard uno de los
más altos pero helados de la Iglesia
Católica francesa de admitió sus abusos
en una declaración escrita el lunes
hace 35 años cuando era sacerdote me
comporté de forma reprobable con una
niña de 14 años mi comportamiento causó
inevitablemente consecuencias graves y
duraderas en esta persona
la confesión del cardenal se produce
apenas un mes después de otro caso de
abuso sexuales que sacudió a la iglesia
católica el exobispo del critea Michelle
Santiago se retiró el año pasado tras
ser acusado de hacer desnudar a chicos
jóvenes por cada pecado confesado una
investigación independiente realizada en
2021 estimó más de 200.000 víctimas de
abusos por parte del clero en Francia
desde los años 50
el hecho de la celebración de esta rueda
de prensa sobre la revelación relativa
al cardenal ricard toda esta
evidentemente relacionado hay una mayor
concienciación en la iglesia
católicas franceses han sido acusados de
violencia sexual o de no denunciar en
los casos de abuso y se enfrentan a un
juicio o a un tribunal eclesiástico los
obispos deben anunciar el martes las
medidas disciplinarias que pondrán en
marcha para acabar con la impunidad en
la iglesia
la conversación Es sobre este tema es
cuando de Silvia Roxana pizzeda
cofundadora de adultese por los derechos
de la infancia un colectivo
independiente y conformado por
sobrevivientes de abuso que busca dar
visibilidad al delito de abuso sexual en
la infancia con la finalidad de incidir
en la defensa de la niñez y también de
sus derechos Silvia Gracias a ustedes
por darnos de su tiempo y de su
experiencia
no es un gusto estar hablando Hoy acá
con muchas gracias mire Silvia
Lamentablemente la Iglesia Católica nos
da la oportunidad para seguir hablando
de abusos y abusos además en la infancia
el Papa Francisco dijo recientemente que
aunque a veces no se nota la iglesia
católica si trabaja arduamente para
combatir estos crímenes al interior de
la institución y este reporte de obispos
O podría ser una muestra de ello sin
embargo Quiero preguntarle a usted si
cree que es cierto lo que dice el papá
que ese trabajo arduo se Está realizando
nosotros creemos como sobrevivientes el
secreto de abuso y después de tantos
años de experiencia de haber sufrido
nuestros abusos y de haber visto la
sociedad que teníamos yo tengo 55 años
cuando fui abusada se lo dije a mis
padres mis padres no hicieron nada y a
los 42 años me tuve que encontrar
protegiendo a mi hija de un progenitor
abusador y encontrarme nuevamente en el
año 2009 con una sociedad que le costaba
muchísimo entender que existíamos los
sobrevivientes de abuso que también los
abusadores están entre nosotros y
nosotras y por eso digo yo esto nosotros
lo vemos con mucha esperanza porque
creemos que en verdad que una
institución como la Iglesia Católica se
vea obligada a replantearse su postura
con respecto a los derechos humanos de
infancia y de muchos de sus de sus de
las personas que han formado parte de
esta iglesia católica que han sido
responsables de una grave violación de
derechos humanos de infancia se ve
obligada a tomar estas medidas nosotros
creemos que es por la lucha nuestra por
la lucha de las víctimas y de los
sobrevivientes y desde hace décadas
venimos de a poco muchas veces muchos
individualmente luego muchos pudimos
conformar colectivos unirnos en redes y
sumar nuestras voces y estamos obligando
aquí a que personas de poder
instituciones tengan que replantearse
sus prácticas por eso nosotros nos vemos
con alegría esto a pesar de que es
insuficiente a pesar de que se necesitan
mucho más compromiso de toda la sociedad
adulta nos parece muy importante y los
festejamos como un logro de los millones
de compañeros y compañeras que en algún
momento nos hemos animado a empezar a
hablar a contar lo que nos ha pasado y a
pedir justicia mire Silvia
jugar la tengo que interrumpir para que
vayamos haciendo más preguntas y
avanzando en el tema porque ustedes les
decía algo muy importante al inicio de
su intervención y es bueno aclararlo
también para nuestros televidentes que
esto no se trata simplemente de un
señalamiento a la iglesia católica
sucedió en este caso el reporte en el
ámbito de la Iglesia Católica pero el
contexto de abuso de la infancia y en
general de mujeres y bueno en algunos
casos de hombres también
se da en Los entornos cercanos y eso es
lo clave aquí la mayoría de abusos
ocurren por parte de personas conocidas
personas familiares y esto es algo que
está completamente normalizado al día de
hoy la gente todavía no entiende la
gravedad de que sucedan tocamientos no
deseados acoso callejero acoso dentro
del hogar y en los peores casos por
supuesto abusos sexuales
claro totalmente nosotros nos parece muy
importante porque estos dentro de la
Iglesia Católica porque cada adulto y
cada institución se tiene que hacer
responsable de los actos de lo que ha
hecho ya dañado un infancia Por eso nos
parece un gesto importante y me parece
que hay que continuar con esta búsqueda
de verdad con las denuncias de los que
son sobrevivientes de los delitos de
abuso eclesiástico como en cualquier
otro orden religioso o de cualquier
ámbito lo que tenemos que acordarnos
como vos decías Es que la mayoría de
nosotros y nosotras fuimos abusados por
personas de nuestra confianza nos han
abusado nuestros familiares nuestros
docentes los pastores los los curas en
los clubes a los que hemos participado
la mayoría de lo que fuimos ajustados y
de las que fuimos abusados en la
infancia fuimos abusadas por personas
que tenían que cuidarnos por eso es tan
importante que como adultos y hoy
sepamos que hicimos la absoluta
responsabilidad de cambiar la suerte de
los niños y las niñas de hoy como
cuidadores y además Silvia porque la
Iglesia También es cuidadora y es el
líder de una espiritualidad de las
personas ahora una crítica enorme contra
estos casos Es que la mayoría de veces
ni siquiera llegan a distancias penales
la iglesia los maneja de forma interna
muchas veces solamente trasladan
sacerdotes de un lugar a otro qué tan
importante es llegar a estas etapas
judiciales
es fundamental que ante algo tan
desordenado como es un adulto abuse de
un niño niña o adolescente
necesitamos que el estado tome su rol de
defensa los derechos de infancia y su
rol como gran ordenador social y por
supuesto que estos casos además de tener
todos sus modos de investigación Y de
alguna manera de respuesta dentro de la
Iglesia Católica Por supuesto que tiene
que haber juicio condena por parte de
los estados Claro pero esta pregunta yo
se la hacía yo se le hacía precisamente
porque aunque la distancia judicial es
muy importante y usted lo detalla muy
bien realmente lo que necesita una
víctima pasa más allá de una sentencia
judicial muy rápidamente que es lo
primordial para la reparación de un niño
de una niña que ha sido víctima de abuso
nosotros lo que vemos es que lo más
importante ser escuchado escuchada con
respeto con amor con empatía tener en
cuenta y transmitírselo al niño o niña
que el único la única responsable y
culpable de lo que le sucedió es el
adulto el niño o niña o adolescente es
una víctima absoluta no tenía chance no
tuvimos chance cuando nos encontramos
con nuestros agresores no tuvimos chance
de hacer una historia diferente y lo más
importante además de eso de creer de
tener en claro que en total rechazo
tiene que ser hacia los agresores
nosotros consideramos que tenemos hasta
ahora una sociedad que es muy permisiva
con los agresores nosotros hablamos del
permiso social al abuso sexual contra
niños niñas y adolescentes en la familia
tienen los entornos tiene que producirse
un profundo rechazo cuando hay alguien
que se animó a contarlo la familia los
los grupos de pertenencia tienen que
tomar estas palabras como la oportunidad
primero de en verdad mi mar cuidar
proteger apachurrar al que se está
animando a hablar y a la que se está
animando a hablar pero por otro lado
marcar el profundo rechazo a los
agresores claro
un cambio que es muy importante para
todos los que hemos sufrido este delito
y para los niños y niñas que hoy están
pasando por esto yo ni siquiera diría
importante yo diría absolutamente
fundamental para una sociedad que en
algún momento aspiramos sea una sociedad
sana la Iglesia Católica ha sido un
referente de patriarcado de esas
relaciones de poder en las cuales
ocurren los entornos de abuso un niño es
una persona indefensa que no tiene las
herramientas para denunciar porque eres
una persona que además aparte de ser
sujeto de derechos pues no los entiende
todavía no los maneja todavía y es
nuestro deber como adultos hacer que se
cumplan esos derechos Como muy
rápidamente sirve porque ya estamos
llegando al final del programa podemos
proteger a nuestras niñas y a nuestros
niños donde podemos detectar esas claves
de entornos abusivos de las que debemos
protegerlos
hace falta una aldea creemos que tiene
que estar una aldea adulta de buena
voluntad activamente protegiendo los
derechos de infancia y atentos Y atentas
a lo que está sucediendo con los niños y
niñas creemos que la suerte de los niños
y niñas no tienen que ser la suerte de
la lotería genética que te tocó en qué
casa naciste si Naciste en una casa
donde te protegen está todo bien y si
nacieron una casa donde estás
desprotegida Vas a tener esa suerte por
eso creemos en la aldea y lo que
nosotros sabemos y hemos visto es que
todos nosotros y nosotros vos pensáis
que nosotros hace 10 años tenemos grupo
de pares donde el sábado a sábado nos
reunimos a hablar sobrevivientes adultos
y un dolor muy grande que tenemos es que
nosotros decimos estuvimos en escuelas
estuvimos en clubes estuvimos dentro de
nuestras familias como múltiples
síntomas con muchísimos cambios de
conducta y nadie se dio cuenta nosotros
nos damos cuenta que pasado como
invisibilizadas también dentro de esta
sociedad que no vio todo el sufrimiento
que cargamos a partir de haber sufrido
los abusos por eso nosotros decimos que
ante cualquier cambio ante cualquier
conducta que vemos en un niño o niña que
nos llama la atención prender la alarma
y pensar que quizás está pasando por
algo realmente doloroso y que no se nos
está y no se está animando a hablar por
eso es tan importante y los ámbitos
donde los niños y niñas puedan contar lo
que le sucede
sean los clubes hay que tener formación
y muchas ganas de mirar a los niños y de
salir a defenderlos activamente cuando
pensamos que están sufriendo pues nos
quedamos entonces con ese mensaje Silvia
gracias a ustedes y gracias a nuestros
televidentes por la experiencia y el
análisis acerca de cómo los entornos
deben ser protectores para la infancia y
para la adolescencia sigan en Francia 24
y en France 24.com nos vemos
Próximamente en ella soy
[Música]